on va passer au débat de ce club on va
parler de crpool et des suites de
l'affaire de crpool parce que Steve et
bien cette affaire elle continue à
agiter la sphère politique oui on va
voir cette minute de silence organisée
hier à l'Assemblée nationale hommage à
Thomas 16 ans poignarnier dans la nuit
du 18 au 19 novembre dans la drô hommage
qui a été décidé en conférence des
présidents mardi matin un déchaînement
de violence a fait basculer une commune
française dans l'horreur pour Thomas en
signe de solidarité avec ses parents sa
famille ses amis ses proches je vous
demande mesdames et messieurs les
membres du gouvernement mesdames et
messieurs les députés de bien vouloir
observer une minute de
silence voilà ces images de de consensus
qui n'ont pas duré longtemps longtemps
on y reviendra ça contraste en tout cas
avec le discours et les images de ces
derniers jours on va voir ces images qui
ont été tournées en plein centre de Lyon
lundi soir une c de militants
d'ultradroite ont marché dans la ville
avec pour slogan justice pour Thomas
Islam hors d'Europe h personnes ont été
interpellées par la police des
manifestations de ce type il y en a eu
plusieurs partout en France depuis la
mort de Thomas roman suriser le weekend
dernier mais aussi à Reims à Rennes ou
encore à l'aval en réaction le
gouvernement a annoncé la dissolution de
plusieurs groupes d'ultra drroite
écoutez je condamne avec la plus grande
fermeté les démonstrations et les actes
de violence de l'ultra drroite ces
derniers jours
la justice ne vient jamais de la
violence nous ne laisserons rien passer
des moyens nombreux sont mis pour suivre
les 1500 personnes radicalisé de l'ultra
droite pour pouvoir les interpeller pour
engager les procédures de dissolution
comme je l'ai fait avec Génération
identitaire comme je le ferai demain
avec la division Martel qui sera
présentée au prochain conseil des
ministres et deux autres groupuscules
d'extrême droite connaissent aujourd'hui
des contradictoires qui permettront je
l'espère aprèsdain d'être dissous voilà
l'ultraadroite en France représente
environ 3000 personnes au total 1300
d'entre elles seraient fichers S et on
va parler hein tout à l'heure Steve des
suites politiques et notamment de cette
passe d'armes entre Éric Dupont maétier
et Marine Le Pen hier mais d'abord
Nicolas Prisset qu'est-ce que cette
affaire de crpol et qu'est-ce que les
suites de cette affaire de crpol disent
de notre société elle montre déjà sur le
plan politique une instrumentalisation
immédiate de l'extrême droite mais c'est
son son modus opérandi j'allais dire de
depuis toujours d'essayer de
d'antagoniser immédiatement après les
les les faits sur le coup de de
l'émotion quand quand tout le monde est
choqué par les images et les
informations et avant même évidemment de
connaître la réalité des faits parce que
pour l'instant le mobile de de de de la
Rix de la TX je sais pas comment il faut
l'appeler parce qu'on ne connaît pas
précisément les faits à crpol le mobile
n'est pas connu le profil des
assaillants appelonlés comme ça disons
des agresseurs c'est un profil qui
commence un peu à être connu mais on les
on les connaît pas tous et donc on a
énormément d'informations qui manquent
et en absence d'information ça ça
dérange pas l'extrême droite de dire
voilà le notre narratif politique c'est
d'expliquer qu'il y a des ordes sauvages
venus des banlieux et d'immigration qui
vont s'en prendre à de pauvres innocent
dans dans un village typique français de
de carte postale donc cette image là
elle fonctionne et cette image politique
elle fonctionne euh elle fonctionne
plutôt bien c'est-à-dire que la société
française il est assez réceptive et et
et ça donne des mobilisation politique
totalement antagonisante comme celle des
des des militants d'extrême droite qui
viennent pour faire bah ce qu'il faut
appeler une sorte de de ratonate puisque
on leur a donné manifestement C
l'information de nos confrères de France
Info hier on leur a donné les noms et
les adresses y compris celles de proche
des agresseurs présumés donc il y a un
phénomène qui est un phénomène qu'on a
déjà connu dans l'histoire dans les
années 70 dans les années 30 de
groupuscules d'extrême droite qui
veulent en quelque sorte Somer le le
chaos dans la
société imposer l'histoire de d'une
société qui serait difficé en deux clans
qui devrai nécessairement se battre et
puis on a dans des phénomènes plus
récents des des des groupuscules qui
sont qu'on dit accélérationiste ça
j'utilise le terme qui est utilisé par
les services de renseignement
accélérationist ça veut dire qu'il vont
aller provoquer les violences pour faire
en sorte que la guerre civile qu'ils
appellent de leur vœux se déroule le
plus vite possible donc on est
aujourd'hui dans cette situation avec
des provocations et des violences qui
doivent absolument être condamnés le le
le plus rapement possible juste un
dernier point je sais c'est un peu long
mais un dernier point euh il y a eu des
comparitions immédiates dans l'affaire
de crpool avec des condamnations à de la
prison ferme
immédiate malgré le fait que cette
extrême droite réclame systématiquement
une justice plus dure la justice elle
est elle passe ça leur suffit pas c'est
bien la preuve que leur intention
politique elle est ailleurs et elle est
dans la violence pierre qu'est-ce que ça
as dit de la société
pour ça dit beaucoup de choses mais j'ai
surtout le sentiment qu'il y a une
responsabilité qui est immense et
responsabilité partagé d'événement en
événement de fait divers en fait
divivers on parle d'ensuvagement on
parle de
décivilisation comme si le fait divhiver
était le fruit d'une représentation
statistique de ce qui se passe dans la
société et je trouve que la manière dont
on interprète dont on surréagit dont on
sur peut-être estime aussi des
événements comme ceux de crpol même si
on n pas encore totalement les
conclusions mais c'est surtout la
manière dont on se jette tout de suite
sur un événement pour en tirer des
conclusions comme le fait l'extrême
droite notamment en disant tout de suite
regardez ce sont des personnes avec des
prénoms à consonance arabophones euh et
que donc du coup l'arabe ou le musulmans
et donc un danger un danger en puissance
pour notre société c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est l'esprit même de
l'instrumentalisation d'un fait divers
c'estàdire c'est on on on tire profit
d'un événement aussi isolé soit-il pour
accréditer des thèses qui sont celles de
l'extrême droite aujourd'hui moi j'ai
j'ai j'ai je je j'ai entendu le le le
propos du du celui qui postula être
Premier ministre au Pays-Bas le nouveau
au chef celui qui est arrivé en tête des
élections le discours de Wilders
wildilders est glaçant il dit nous avons
orté un monstre dans notre pays qui
s'appelle l'islam qui a mis notre pays
en danger l'islam c'est l'idéologie qui
apporte la haine et la terreur c'est
l'ami de Madame Le Pen ce monsieur et il
demande à tous les musulmans qui sont
des dangers des Pays-Bas de quitter les
Pays-Bas ce que je veux dire c'est que
le discours de l'extrême droite
l'instrumentalisation de l'extrême
droite pour stigmatiser des personnes
comme celles qui sont stigmatisées en
permanence les musulmans la figure du
musulman ça sert à ça le fait divers
c'est pour ça que je dis que on a tous
une responsabilité dans
l'instrumentalisation de ces moments là
c'est pour ça que je dis que parler de
décivilisation parler de d'ensuvagement
comme le fait le ministre de l'intérieur
ou même le président de la République
c'est une erreur monumentale c'est une
erreur de d'analyse de ce que l'on vit
en ce moment y compris d'ailleurs le
ministère de l'Intérieur l'explique tous
les événements y compris les plus
radicaux ils étaient beaucoup plus
radicaux il y a encore 20 30 ans
aujourd'hui il y a quand même moins de
mort aujourd'hui dans l'espace public et
dans les événements aussi tragique
soit-il et et encore une fois
l'événement de crpol est un événement
tragique
il faut faire attention sur la lecture
qu'on en fait et et et tout ça conduit à
une chose c'est ce que vous venez de
dire c'est-à-dire que à un moment donné
il y a une manière décomplexée
d'exprimer son racisme dans la rue mais
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui il y a
une occupation de la rue de groupusculle
d'extrême droite de groupusculle néonazi
qui se balade dans la rue avec des
slogans un risque de basculement de la
société c'est ce qu'a dit Olivier
verrant quand il est allé à crpole lundi
je sais pas s'il y a un risque de
basculement mais en tout cas quand je
dis qu' a une responsabilité partagée
sur la manière dont on parle de ces
événements oui produit une espèce de
confusion et qui et d'ailleurs et vous
avez raison de parler de de de de de de
de de de clivage dans la société parce
qu'on a tous l'impression qu'on est au
bord d'une explosion d'une de d'une
guerre civile et y compris les
personnalités d'extrême droite je pense
à pour ne pas le citer Jean Messia qui a
qui est suivi par plusieurs centaines de
dizaines de milliers de de de de
personnes qui est une figure médiatique
de l'extrême droite qui s'exprime
partout et qui explique sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'il va préparer la guerre
civile parce que il faut aller il le
dira pas comme ça mais les compuscules
d'extrême droite on l'a vu dans des
vidéos le disent très clairement il faut
descendre dans la rue pour faire des
ratounades pour aller casser du de
l'arabe pour pas dire le terme qu'ils
utilisent eux-mêmes donc oui il y a une
manière de de de de décomplexer une
extrême droite avec des discours que
parfois une partie de la majorité
politique enfin des des des de la gauche
pas de la gauche enfin une partie de la
gauche si mais aussi surtout de la
droite participe de cette légitimation
de ce discours raciste Nicolas hier
Géral hermanin il est allit encore plus
loin que l'v verérant LV verérant parle
d'imbasculement de la société géraldbin
hier il a dit que la fermeté avait
permis d'éviter un scénario de guerre
civile quand il parle de guerre civile
est-ce qu'il va trop lo ou est-ce qu'il
décrit une réalité possible c'est le
scénario que veut cette extrême droite
donc si le ministère de l'Intérieur est
capable je vais revenir dans un instant
d'enrayer la montée de de la violence
effectivement il il évitera peut-être
pas une guerre civile c'estàd des
Français contre les Français dans
l'intégralité de de la population mais
il permettra d'éviter queil y ait des
personnes qui qui soi blessé ou tué dans
des affrontements à l'intérieur des
cités ou en marge des cités là où l'extr
Noord va aller chercher des des jeunes
euh puisque à ses yeux ils sont issus de
l'immigration donc dangereux donc ça ce
scénario là il est enraillé euh et il
peut l'être parce qu'il y a un travail
de des services de rignement qui est
assez intéressant en ce qui concerne
l'extrême droite il y avait la semaine
dernière un rapport à l'assemblée qui a
été rendu par jéréy Yordanov un un
écologiste et puis Éric pouia pour
Renaissance et qui faisait un peu le le
bilan de ce qu'est l'activisme dangereux
radical extrémiste en France avec ce ce
décompte de 1300 fichiers s à l'ultra
droite al 3000 à l'ultra gauche on peut
y revenir aussi et et sachant que cette
ultr drroite elle est caractérisée par
la volonté de renverser les institutions
et de s'en prendre aux personnes alors
que l'ultra gauche va aller s'attaquer à
la police et et et aux banques pour
résumer euh et donc cette connaissance
de ces réseaux là de ces groupesuscules
là elle permet de d'identifier notamment
les les associations qui qui se
reformment qui sont dissoutes puis après
qui se reforment en petites associations
par ailleurs enfin ça n'éteint pas le
phénomène mais ça disons ça permet d'en
repousser le le les les actions donc il
y a ce travail là qui qui est important
qui donne certains résultats gen
Darmanin il ministre de l'Intérieur donc
il a raison de de de mettre ses
résultats en avant après en ce qui
concerne la réalité de la société
évidemment non il y a pas dans tous les
villes et villages de France des gens
qui en train sont en train de s'armer
pour se battre les uns contre les autres
et heureusement donc on n'est pas du
tout dans ce scénario là mais le fait
que ce soit ce scénario qui s'impose
dans le débat politique là oui c'est
c'est ça ça détourne et ça déforme
complètement la vision de la société et
la vie au quotidien des Français oui je
voulais rajouter une chose la semaine
dernière dans Politi on a fait un
dossier sur la loi asile immigration
qu'on a qu'on a enveloppé on a habillé
ça en l'appelant la la fabrique de la
peur mais ce qui se passe aujourd'hui à
travers un événement comme celui de de
Crépol c'est c'est c'est c'est aussi
d'une certaine manière médias hommes
femm politique on construit quand même
une image où on construit la peur je dis
pas qu'elle est irrationnelle cette peur
parce que on le voit chaque jour il y a
des événements qui nous font craindre
queeffectivement la société bascule mais
en participant de cette de ce discours
de cette fabrique des des préjugés on
parlait tout à l'heure des
discrimination mais il y a aussi
beaucoup trop de préjugés qui circulent
et auxquels on ne prête pas suffisamment
attention l'extrême droite joue de ses
préjugés quand elle utilise un événement
comme celui criple comme elle l'avait
fait à l'époque vous vous souvenez de
l'a l'affaire tragique de de de Lola qui
avait été trouvé morte à Paris on la
première suspecte était une femme
d'origine algérienne tout de suite
l'extrême droite tombe dessus pour dire
regardez les Arabes les musulmans 2
jours ou 3 jours après oui elle avait
elle était s sous le coup d' de
l'unocutf 2 joursou 3 jours après je
crois il y a une jeune fille qui meurt
dans les à peu près mêmes circonstances
20 ans sauf que son le principal suspect
s'appelle romain il est agriculteur
l'extrême droite ne parle pas de cette
affaire 2 jours plus tard pareil une
jeune fille 18 ans retrouvée morte après
avoir été kidnappé son son agresseur
était un jeune qui s'appelait Théo et
qui était intérimaire bon l'extrême
droite ne tombe pas là-dessus donc ce
que je veux dire c'est que l'extrême
droite sait utiliser des événements pour
accrédiser les testes qui sont les
siennes et testes que je rappelais qui
sont celles aujourd'hui d'une personne
qui risque peut-être de prendre le
pouvoir aux Pays-Bas qui va expliquer
qu'il va faire la guerre aux musulmans
qui va les mettre tous dehors Marine Le
Pen est dans le même état d'esprit et et
et et c'est c'est aussi cette volonté de
cliver la société on le voit en
Argentine en Argentine le président qui
vient d'être élu Miley il a il a joué
sur la division des populations la
division des populations entre les
pauvres d'abord mais surtout la division
des populations en mettant en accusation
la figure de l'étranger c'est toujours
la même chose l'extrême droite c'est les
pauvres on les divise entre eux pour
qu'il se s'entretu en disant ah il les
assisté et cetera nous on travaille et
donc et la figure du P du de la figure
d'étranger pareil c'est c'est le même
mécano aujourd'hui et donc la fabrique
de la peur elle est et c'est pour ça que
je rappelais la responsabilité de tout
le monde média comme homme femme
politique c'est aussi dans la fabrique
et de la perception des discours que
l'on crée qu'il faut faire attention
après il y a aussi une réalité et un
contexte qui favorise l'extrême droite
parce que donne donnant écho à son
discours qui est le fait que certains
quartiers et la mer de roman cizer le
dit il 5 qui apparaissent hors de
contrôle parce que il y a une poignée de
gamin ou parfois une centaine qui qui
déroge à toutes les lois et c'est cette
perception que des quartiers sont hors
de contrôle la parce que des dealers ont
pris le pouvoir il y aussi la question
des trafic de Dr pas seulement la vision
des émeutes de l'été dernier c'est aussi
des images et c'est aussi une réalité
qui qui qui nourrit et qui alimente ce
ressentiment et et et cette peur et donc
ça ça reste de mon point de vue un
chantier qui est entier pour l' excutif
qui a promis à maintre reprise la
fermeté sans forcément la délivrer en
tout cas la mettre en œuvre donc on a
aussi un contexte d'ensemble et qui est
particulièrement favorable à cette
antagonisation on va parler d'une passe
d'armes qui a eu lieu hier lors de la
séance de question d'actu à l'Assemblée
passe d'arme entre le rassemblement
national et le gouvernementc duupomti
qui a allumé le feu he dans l'hémicycle
le ministre de la Justice était
interrogé par une députée eren des
Pyrénées orientales qui lui reprochait
le Laxis de notre justice dans le
contexte du meurtre de Thomas éti a
décidé de s'attaquer frontalement au RN
en l'accusant de récupération politique
écoutez vous préférez en réalité opposer
la France rurale et tranquille
catholique et blanche à la France des
cités la France des Mohamed des Mouloud
et des Rachid nos frères juifs ont peur
nos Frères musulmans ont peur aussi sont
incendiaires et ils amènent dans la rue
les militants de l'ultra drroite qui
sont bien plus proches de vous que de
moi pendant l'intervention vous l'avez
vu les députés RN ont quitté l'hémicycle
dans la salle des quatre colonnes Marine
Le Pen a annoncé qu'elle allait porter
plainte contre le ministre de la Justice
écoutez nous allons déposer devant la
Cour de
justice une plainte pour que le
ministre s'explique de ces injures et
accessoirement de ces diffamations voilà
si plainte il y a sera ce sera donc
devant la CJR la Cour de Justice de la
République ERC duupti connait un peu le
consensus en tout cas autour de la
minute de silence à Thomas n'aura pas
duré très longtemps ouais effectivement
on voit lesclivag dans la classe
politique sur cette affaire on va parler
après des républicains Nicolas mais sur
cette passe d'armes hier entre Marine Le
Pen et Éric Dupont Moretti oui Éric
Dupont Moretti il est peut-être dans
dans les les derniers moments de de son
poste au ministère de de la justice et
il a été placé au gouvernement près
gouvernement par Emmanuel Macron
justement pour être dans cette posture
contre contre l'extrême droite parce
qu'on sait que c'est une de ses de ses
qualités et sa capacité à à à aller se
battre verbalement contre contre ce
cette franche de de la vie politique et
donc hier il a fait le job en quelque
sorte et et là où Marine Le Pen et le le
rassemblement national sont dans une
posture on va dire qui qui voudrait
afficher une forme de de sagesse de
depuis un an et et éviter toutes les
aspérités ce qui peut faire polémique et
bien il vient systématiquement c'est pas
la première fois qu'il le fait les
rappeler à leur histoire d'une part et à
la nature profonde de de de leur projet
politique et puis de de ce qui est
constitue une franche de leur électorat
parce qu'il faut rappeler que dans les
enquêtes sociologiques on voit que les
les caractéristiques racistes ou
antisémites elles sont propres à
l'extrême droite dans des proportions
bien plus élevées que pour le restant de
de l'électorat donc il a ce jeu qui
est quelque sorte celui pour lequel il a
été placé à cet endroit il le fait
peut-être pour la dernière fois et et
Marine Le Pen elle elle continue sa
posture de comment dire de de personne
qui a rien à se reprocher et puis qui ce
serait hier fait agressé par le Garde
des saau est-ce qu'il y aura vraiment
une plainte est-ce qu'elle aboutira ça
c'est quand même une hypothèse voilà on
peut doutter il a eu raison de
s'exprimer comme ça dans les mythies du
Parlement et du PTI pierre je sais pas
s'il survivra à cette journée contenu
du le procès enfin les conclusions du
procès devrai arriver autour de 15h je
crois euh je n'aurais pas eu beaucoup
l'occasion depuis qu'il est nommé garde
des saut pour de dire du bien de de de
de sa manière de faire de la politique
mais j'aime je ferai je fer je ferai
toujours euh je serai toujours en accord
avec le gouvernement quand il s'agira de
combattre l'extrême droite mais le
combattre comme il faut et je pense
qu'il l'a fait avec les mots et les le
verbe qui est le sien qui est très
talentueux on sait qu'il a quand même un
un talent oratoire qui est qui est
efficace et hier il l'a été ave just ou
les mot il est allé trop loin non les
mots sont justes je crois qu'à un moment
donné il faut nommer ce qui est
l'extrême droite et il a nommé euh le
l'extrême droite comme il le fallait en
rappelant les liens de l'extrême droite
avec les le Gude les les groupeul
d'extrême droite donc je trouve qu'il a
eu le mot et et le ton juste il faut
être ferme avec l'extrême droite
j'aimerais qu'il le soit d'autant plus
quand ils font des projets de loi comme
ceux sur sur l'immigration qui est en ce
moment en train d'être débattu au par
tapé sur la franceç on l'a pas entendu
c'est vrai il y a aussi ce passage où il
explique que d'un côté on l'accuse d'un
certain nbre de choses et de l'autre
côté en citant en montrant la gauche du
doigt qu'effectivement que la gauche qui
accuse le gouvernement d'être
islamophobe et vous comprenez la
réaction de Marine Le Pen qui a annoncé
qui dit que c'est une insulte envers les
millions de Français Marine Le Pen ouis
il faut arrêter il faut d'abord qu'elle
arrête de penser que les millions
d'électeurs sont lui appartiennent
certes elle a fait des très bons scores
et elle a un peu progressé aux dernières
élections nationales mais Marine Le Pen
fait ce que les Le Pen d' manière
générale ça faire de mieux depuis
l'existence du Front national avec
Jean-Marie Le Pen c'est la victimisation
elle est dans la victimisation
c'estàdire que dès qu'il est question
d'une attaque personnelle d'une attaque
politique elle considère aujourd'hui que
c'est de la diffamation très bien
qu'elle porte ça devant les tribunaux je
suis pas sûr que ça aille très loin
parce qu'ils bénéficent tous au sein du
Parlement quand même d'une immunité donc
elle est dans une forme de de elle s'en
fout en fait d'ailleurs de quelles
seront les conclusions d'une poss
possible procédure judiciaire elle est
dans la victimisation elle veut montrer
qu'elle est la victime qu'elle est celle
qui est qui est antiystème que tout le
monde veut combattre au sein de de ce
Parlement c'est ça qu'elle fait en fait
en en réagissant tout de suite après les
propos du garde des saau en plus dans un
contexte où on sait que le Gard sa
lui-même fragilisé ouais on on on va y
venir pour terminer cette émission mais
juste sur les réactions à cette affaire
de crpol parce que on a parlé du du
rassemblement
national ce qui s'est passé hier mais
sur les réactions au manivre de l'ultra
droite Jordan Bardella le président du
RN il s'est désolidarisé des violences
qui ont eu lieu lors de ces
manifestations éic sooti le président
des républicains lui il a été beaucoup
plus mesuré il a refusé de les condamner
il dit moi ce qui me choque c'est
l'assassinat de Thomas point final oui
alors il a mis du temps avant de les
condamner en fait ericotti mais là on
voit les différences de stratégie avec
un métro de retard pour pour Eric soti J
il a fait une erreur en disant ça ou
bien sûr Jordan Bardella il est dans la
poursuite de la stratégie de
normalisation et de banalisation du
rassemblement national donc
évidemment il ne peut que continuer et
poursuivre l'œuvre qui a été celle de
Marine le père à savoir se détacher de
tout ce qui peut apparaître au sein de
leur parti comme étant des des des
extrémistes des racistes des antisémites
et et il faut se souvenir que Marine Le
Pen a systématiquement démis de de leur
fonction de de de de de leur candidature
quand il était question d'investiture
des personnalités pour lesquelles on
trouvait sur Facebook ou sur les réseaux
sociaux des expressions qui qui
pouvaient tomber sur le coup de la loi
et donc elle a eu ce ce ce travail làà
et puis Jordan Bardella le poursuit et
donc forcément il tient ce ce type de
propos vis-à-vis de des des uscule
d'extrême droite même si on l'a rappelé
il y a quelques instants les liens sont
historiques il y a des liens historiques
donc Eric cioti qui on le voit depuis
plusieurs années était dans une
tentative de récupérer l'électorat parti
au rassemblement national en calquant
une large partie de son discours
notamment sur l'immigration avec des
propositions qui sont identiques à
celles du rassemblement national bien là
il il est en quelque s un peu en retard
il a voulu peut-être avoir c une
manœuvre tactique pour tenter de de de
d'apparaître comme étant encore plus dur
que les dur mais ça n' pas March s fait
piéger mais il s ou il s'est fait piéger
il est piégé par le Ren aujourd'hui
exactement pierre il est est-ce qu'éic
soti il est piégé quand on voit que
Jordane Bardella a une réaction plus
mesurée j'ai pas le sentiment qu'il est
piégé en tout cas j'ai pas l'impression
qu'on l'oblige ericotti il est convaincu
par ce qu'il dit je pense il est
convaincu par les thèses qui sont les
siennes il est convaincu par le
programme enfin par la structure
idéologique de de ce qui est aujourd'hui
le rassemblement national et
que en réalité il est totalement
rassemblement national compatible
monsieur chti ça rappelle une chose
quand même parce que je sais que depuis
quelques temps on l'a vu avec les
mouvements sociaux les les mouvements
écologistes on a quand même toujours
souvent dit et le ministre de
l'Intérieur l' beaucoup dit que la
gauche était la principale menace
aujourd'hui enfin la gauche les
écoloterroristes et cetera mais c'est
quand même on a quand même devant nos
yeux ce qui est la principale menace
aujourd'hui dans notre pays qui est
quand même la menace de l'extrême droite
et Monsieur soioti on ne voulant pas
condamner ce qui est ce que sont des
ratonades clairement ce que sont des
mobilisations dans l'espace public de
groupesc d'extrêm en ne voulant pas
condamner il légitime ce genre de de de
de de de mobilisation et il rend
légitime la parole raciste et donc oui
monsieur soioti qui d'ailleurs j'ai vu
dans un tweet accuse monsieur Mélanchon
d'être le danger je pense que le danger
il est de ce côté-là de ce de ce côté
qui légitime ou en tout cas qui banalise
l'expression radicale d'une extrême
droite qui est complètement décomplexée
et qui s'expre aujourd'hui dans les rue
de France on va terminé par un mot sur
du pomti he puisque vous l'avez dit il
connaîtra son seur judiciaire à 15h où
sera rendue la décision de Cour de
Justice de la République est-ce que
quelle que soit la décision il est un
ministre affaibli Nicolas pr oui bien
sûr il est un ministre affaibli après ça
va dépendre aussi de des conclusions de
la façon dont dont elles sont rédigées
des mots qui seront prononcés mais le
scénario dans lequel on est aujourd'hui
c'est quand même un scénario dans lequel
il risque fortement d'être d'être
condamné alors après il peut faire un
pourvoir en cassation ce qui serait
suspensif donc l'histoire est peut-être
pas totalement terminé mais il est quand
même dans une situation de grande
fragilité Pier oui et puis est pas le
seul enfin dans le gouvernement quand
même avec monsieur dusop qui est aussi
dans une procédure judiciaire c'est qu'
enfin on a tous en tête ce propos
d'Emmanuel Macron qui avait lui-même dit
en étant candidat que n'importe quel
ministre mis en examen il devrait
démissionner et ça paraît à peu près
effectivement logique contenu de des
engagements d'Emmanuel Macron en faveur
de la
probité et plus largement la classe
politique donc oui il est évidemment
très affaibli et il serait surréaliste
si effectivement il était condamné
aujourd'hui qu'il parte en appel à la
Cour de cassation
il en a le droit non mais certes il en a
le droit non ce que je veux dire non il
en a le droit mais qu'il ne démissionne
pas en en faisant option d'aller porter
le le jugement en cours de cassation
mais ça serait incompréhensible on
suivra cette décision à 15h et on en
parlera évidemment demain on va reparler
de l'ultradroite c'est de la presse
[Musique]
régionale et on reparle de l'ultra
droite Steve puis par que l'ultra droite
c'est également la une de la presse
régionale le retour des milices titre La
Marseillaise le quotidien revient sur
les rassemblements de ces derniers jours
expédition punitive défilé dans
plusieurs villes de France La
Marseillaise veut tirer la sonnette
d'alarme la vermine ressurgit écrit le
quotidien dans son éedito après la
période des années 30 40 on pensait que
les citoyens européens étaient immunisés
il n'en est rien nous dit la
Marseillaise un habitant de rouand dans
le viseur de la justice oui c'est la Une
de parisnormandie Léo r dit gros lard a
participé à l'expédition punitive menée
par l'ultra drroite à roman sur rizer
après le décès de Thomas Paris Normandie
retrace son parcours il s'agit d'un
ancien employé de la grande distribution
originaire de la région lyonnaise gros
lardon comme il se fait appeler et bien
connu de dans la sphère de l'extrême
droite enquête à lire à suivre dans
Paris-Normandie on parle d'un autre
sujet stop à la clop stop la clope c'est
un nouveau coup de vis du gouvernement
c'est fait la Une de l'Alsace ce matin
la cigarette bannie est bientôt hors de
prix d'ici à 2027 le paquet de cigarette
passera à 13 € le gouvernement a
présenté ce mardi son plan de lutte
contre le tabagisme les espaces sans
tabac vont être élargis interdiction de
fumé dans les parcs dans les jardins aux
abords des lieux publics notamment les
établissements scolaires on compte
encore 12 millions de fumeurs quotidiens
en France le gouvernement espère que ces
nouvelles mesures vont faire chuter le
nombre de consommateurs le prix des
pommes de terre explose oui et la Voix
du Nord nous explique pourquoi en un an
le prix du kilo de patate a pris 23 %
les récoltes ont été mauvaises il y a eu
les intempéries l'explosion les tarifs
de l'énergie les causes sont nombreuses
le prix de la patate explose les
consommateurs n'ont plus la frite on
salue nos frères de la voie du Nord pour
ce titre qui est en page intérieur le
Nord sans s frites c'est plus vraiment
le Nord évidemment le 4 € le petit
cornet de frites vous imaginez c'est
énorme noël arrive oui Noël arrive ah on
do se dépêcher noël arrive certains ont
déjà acheté le sapin le populaire du
centre s'intéresse à ce que les Français
mettront sous le sapin on apprend que le
marché de la seconde main explose pour
des raisons écologiques et ou financi
près de la moitié des Français sont
prêts à offrir des cadeaux d'occasion à
Noël pour leur proches merci Steve la de
poli c'est la C 28 transition met un
Politi sous le sapin à Noël oh là là
c'est
beau ça mettez un Politi sous le sapin
Nicolas qu'est-ce qu'on peut
lireon comme ça c'est dit aussi et
évidemment on suit avec beaucoup de
précision et d'intérêt la situation
politique et ce qui se passe autour de
l'extrême droite et on lira ça dimanche
avec grand intérêt merci Nicol merci
merci d'avo é a nousci prochain
rendez-vous à 15h sé de question d'ctité
au gouvernement au sén et puis à 18h
public très bonne journée à
demain